violent demonstrations in kazakhstan
sparked by rising fuel prices in an
oil-rich nation protesters now called
for leadership change russia responds to
the president's plea for help and sends
troops so what more is behind the unrest
in this former soviet republic
this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm kim
vanell
a russian-led alliance has deployed
troops as peacekeepers to kazakhstan
after the president asked for help to
quell mass demonstrations across the
country
they began on january 1st after the
government announced a sharp increase in
fuel prices indignation and violence
followed in an effort to calm the unrest
the government resigned
the president then declared a two-week
nationwide state of emergency and a
shutdown of the internet
but still the protests escalated into
calls for a change in leadership
demonstrators say they've run out of
patience while president kasim jomah
tokaiv is blaming the unrest on foreign
actors
dear journalists and bloggers many
versions of what's happened here have
been told you have to understand what's
happened here the coiled springs now
been unleashed after 30 years look all
of us have been fired upon all of us
went through these things but none of us
wants to kill or put pressure on another
person
please come here and see it with your
own eyes we show you the face of a new
country and you should witness it we
kazak people have patience so stop it
we're sick of this look soldiers are
advancing here let them see it all stay
with us and let us see where it goes
the terrorist mobs are essentially
international they underwent serious
training abroad and their attacks of
kazakhstan can be and should be viewed
as an act of aggression for this reason
relying on the collective security
treaty i reached out to the heads of the
collective security treaty organization
states to assist kazakhstan in
overcoming this terrorist threat in
reality it is no longer a threat it is
undermining the state's integrity and
most importantly it is an attack on our
citizens who are asking me as the head
of the state to help them immediately
russia's foreign ministry said it was
closely monitoring the situation saying
in a statement we advocate the peaceful
resolution of all problems within the
constitutional and legal framework and
dialogue rather than through street
rights and the violation of laws
adding that it was the aim of kazakh
president kasim jomah takayev to
stabilize the situation and resolve
existing problems quickly including
those contained in the legitimate
demands of the protesters
speaking on behalf of the u.n secretary
general stefan dejarik urged restraint
following with
concern and monitoring the situation
in kazakhstan
i think it's very important for all
involved in these current events to
exercise restraint refrain from violence
and promote
dialogue in addressing all of the
pertinent issues and further reaction
came from the white house which denied
any involvement in the protests
we're monitoring reports of protests in
kazakhstan we support calls for calm for
protesters to express themselves
peacefully and for authorities to
exercise restraint
there are some crazy
russian claims about the us being behind
this so let me just use this opportunity
to convey that as absolutely false and
clearly a part of the standard russian
disinformation playbook we've seen a lot
of in past years
well kazakhstan is an oil-rich country
in central asia it's the size of western
europe with an ethnically diverse
population of 18 million people it
gained independence from the soviet
union in 1991 but it's remained a close
ally of russia which borders it to the
north kazakhstan is also a crucial
transport hub for chinese products
heading to europe from the east
it has kept a delicate balance between
its neighbors and the west especially
the united states which it sees both as
a potential source for trade and
investment and as a partner to balance
the influence of russia and china in
central asia
[Music]
let's now bring in our guests from
prague we have bruce penny a veteran
journalist and correspondent at radio
free europe specializing in central asia
from belgrade we have victor olivich who
is the lead expert at the center for
actual politics
and on the line from al marti
kazakhstan's largest city we have asea
torisova who's a political activist uh
very well welcomed to the program to you
all now the reason that she is on the
phone line is because the internet has
been cut uh so it makes you know doing a
zoom very difficult as well as getting
information out very difficult uh i'd
like to come to you first asia just tell
us what's the latest there on the ground
in terms of these protests and in terms
of the reaction to them
uh well
we are currently
on a lockdown
the
everyone is
we are advised to stay home and
because
it's not safe to be
on the streets due to
a so-called anti-terrorist operation
that is in progress
what do you make of these assertions i
see that
from the president that these protests
are
coming from foreign actors terrorists
who are causing this unrest
um
you see
everything is so unclear now but there
are definitely forces who use the
protest in their own interests which is
not sure
and we're all cut off from each other
and we have no
reliable information to judge to have
like a complete understanding of the
situation of the growing situation
okay are there protesters who are from
kazakhstan are they among the people the
many thousands of people we're looking
at right now who are are out on the
streets
they're just uh know it's
some people are just people uh just uh
simple protesters who like uh
came
to
uh
um
i mean angry people who
have uh
um
just have
been at it's just
you know it's a mix right now it's hard
to tell who are on the streets i mean if
the protest uh started as a peaceful
protest uh like two days uh it was a
peaceful march
on the streets uh from uh um
like uh um
but it it started somewhere in the west
of the city and then the people
peacefully marched towards the
the the
city city hall and
they were faced with um
tear gas and
and apparently it caused
it turned like a peaceful march or
yeah into uh
into into violence which is what we're
looking at the pictures we're looking at
right now okay i want to cross over uh
to bruce paneer who is in prague
explain to our viewers how country has
gotten to this point why are we seeing
these protests now
you know i mean everything it started
out of course with the pres with the
protest in the far west of kazakhstan
over the hike and the price of fuel
that was doubled it was just it involved
a few dozen people in an oil workers
town called jonos and now um you know
with the the the real
point watershed moment i think for this
study is probably march 2019 when they
changed presidents uh first president
nurse nazarbayev stepped down from power
after 28 years as as the country's
leader
and he handed over power to his to his
own chosen successor uh qasim zama
jamaat
at that point i think a lot of people
thought figured that this was going to
be a moment when kazakhstan took a turn
to a different direction a little bit
you know that that some reform long
overdue reforms would be implemented
standard living would start to improve
more um you know really none of that's
happened uh since that i mean some
changes but no but not much that's why
it's it's interesting that you know
these protests when they started um and
as they gathered steam the demands that
people were making were really the
demands that we've been hearing for a
couple years now uh they wanted more a
greater role in in the political system
and picking their own leaders and that
this was specifically something that
people pointed out when they would send
local officials to talk to the
protesters they would say we didn't have
a chance to elect you you're not elected
officials and we don't recognize you
this is not new uh it's something that's
been more repeated in the last few days
but it's not a new complaint at all you
know and as far as like uh you know
increase in wages because inflation is
going up of course these things are all
common uh common demands that they've
been making for a long time which is why
it's strange that they just do this
foreign influence because the complaints
are absolutely domestic and they've been
there well that was my next question
before we move on uh bruce panea
was then the spread of these protests
from this one region to the rest of the
country was that a surprise at all and
what should we make of of the
president's response so far
well yes it was i mean i got to admit it
was a surprise there have been a lot of
strikes on a lot of protests in western
kazakhstan certainly last year uh you
know so the fact that it went all the
way from the west to the east and really
was in every major town and city in
kazakhstan was was definitely a shock
how fast it went um you know the
authorities did try to make some
concessions but this was a an old tactic
for them of giving giving something to
the protesters and as i said uh some of
this unrest has been simmering for a
couple years i think it just needed you
know something to spark it and that's
really what we've seen in the last four
days
right well crossover now uh to belgrade
where we have victor olivich
how is the russian president vladimir
putin likely to be viewing these
developments
well this uh has this tyranny of events
in kazakhstan has been a
surprise and
sort of an unexpected uh it's an
unexpected turn of events for moscow
and it comes at a sensitive time
when moscow is preparing for
negotiations with the united states and
with nato
uh on the security guarantees in europe
and on ukraine
uh this uh is uh hardly going it's
hardly going to make russia's
negotiating positions stronger in fact
if russia's involvement in uh
in kazakhstan through the collective
security treaty organization if it goes
sour
this will negatively impact this will
weaken russia's position
uh in the upcoming negotiations so this
is definitely not something moscow was
looking for
uh especially at this time or at any
time kazakhstan
is an important ally for moscow uh it is
the largest
state in central asia it is the
both territorially and economically it
is the second largest country in the
eurasian economic union
where russia dominates
and so for russia it is very important
to keep kazakhstan
both a member of the eurasian economic
union and the member of the collective
treaty organization collective security
treaty organization
so when
russia
saw that the situation in kazakhstan
was
getting out of control uh and um
it was happening quite fast and uh when
russia
deemed that the kazakh leadership was
unable to
deal with the situation calm the
situation on its own
and when the uh president of kazakhstan
archive
essentially issued a uh
call for the collective security treaty
organization to intervene uh russia
belarus armenia and several other states
agreed to do so
now there are several other important
points as to what's going on in
kazakhstan that have still not been made
of course the trigger
for the current situation was the as
bruce correctly pointed out was the
severe increase in gas prices however
the president of kazakhstan takayev
has
essentially used
these protests been able to use this uh
critical this crisis
to
sideline and essentially remove
the former president of kazakhstan
azerbaijav who still had an important
position in kazakhstan as the head of
the nation's security council and as a
uh as a uh
so-called yield basis or father of the
nation uh who ruled kazakhstan for
several decades he has been able to
remove him
from kazakhstan's political sphere but
wasn't was it a lot of it wasn't a lot
of the anger wasn't a lot of the anger
or at least some of the anger from the
protesters directed at the former
president
exactly exactly and it is very
interesting
that that anger has been channeled
effectively channeled by the current
president of kazakhstan by takayev to
both remove uh uh nazarbayev from the
political uh landscape of kazakhstan and
also remove nazarbayev's uh
colleagues those who were his loyalists
from the government so essentially on
the third day of protests tokiv
announced the resignation of uh
nazarbayev's close ally askar mahmin who
was the prime minister of kazakhstan and
put his own ally in his play in mamin's
please okay yesterday
removed the head of the national
security uh committee who was also
nazarbayev's ally so this is a
transformation of kazakhstan uh in a
political uh way also and takriv at
first was interested in
in a way used
these protests directed against
nazarbayev uh in his own favor but at
this point some of the protests got out
of hand and archive needs uh needs
assistance from abroad as he states we
will come back to you in a moment uh i
want to go back down the line uh to asia
torisova who i believe we still have on
the phone from almaty if you can hear me
asia i just want to ask you
some of the reasons why people have been
so angry in terms of the cost of living
i mean it's interesting that these
protests started you know in an area
which it was experiencing a boom uh
an energy boom and yet those same people
are struggling with the rising cost of
fuel so just talk me through some of
those reasons why people have been taken
to the streets
yeah i mean it's just i think it's a it
has
it's a cumulative
uh it's a sort of uh the protest
accumulated over the years because uh
for the past years and
even decades people have
made countless attempts to have a
peaceful dialogue with the government
and they
protested for fair pay
protection of land fair elections
battle living conditions
but i think
none of their demands
have never been addressed and
over the years all the attempts were
brutally suppressed
and with many
participants
killed or put to jail
or named terrorists and i think it's
it's uh
what is happening
it just
yeah
did i answer your question you did you
did answer answer my question it's
accumulated over time i'd like to cross
over uh to prague bruce penier i was
interested to see that a spokesperson
for the russian president said that no
foreign forces should interfere in
kazakhstan's affairs what should we make
of that is that a threat and and would
the west ever respond
that's a distraction uh there's there's
really no evidence that any foreign
forces have interfered in kazakhstan's
internal affairs in the last few days or
or are even interested in doing that uh
you know you pointed out that the the
kazakhstan has been been fairly adept at
balancing its foreign policy uh between
china russia and the west
no one in the west wants to see uh
turmoil and instability in kazakhstan
any more than anyone in russia or china
would want to see that either um so this
is just one of those you know vague
illusions that
create a boogeyman that you can point to
for being responsible
for what the problems are and you know
that's what even in president takaya's
comments on last night all of a sudden
he referred to you know terrorist bans
who had been uh who had received foreign
training you know and again there was
there's really no evidence to suggest
that anybody that's been out on the
streets in kazakhstan protesting uh is
an agent of some foreign terrorist group
or anything uh you know
so
it's just one of those one of those
catch phrases that the kremlin and not
just the kremlin but other countries
throw out there and say well you know we
don't want interference from outside
well
you know that's that's pretty vague and
and uh really there's there's nothing to
show that that's there's any truth to
that is there any eventuality is there
any turn of events that could happen in
kazakhstan that would draw the west in
you're saying that kazakhstan has tried
to play a diplomatic balancing game over
the years is there anything that might
draw the uh the engagement of the west
i i i really can't see that happening to
tell you the truth um
it's the kazakhstan's still a long ways
from the west certainly a long ways from
the united states for example uh you
know that i think a lot of countries
would be willing to help kazakhstan to
get through a traumatic time uh help
them sort out any turmoil that's in
there but you know what you can't
imagine a western intervention really in
any country in central asia but
certainly in kazakhstan it would be
impossible logistically it would be it
would be practically impossible how
would you bring any forces or any major
uh
amount of people or personnel into
kazakhstan you'd have to almost you have
to go through china or russia and if you
don't go through china or russia then
you have a long route to get in there so
it's really
uh you know i think there's been an
understanding for a long time between
the west and kazakhstan that the west is
only able to help kazakhstan so much and
and both sides appreciate that uh
certainly everyone in the west wants to
see a strong sovereign
independent kazakhstan that's able to
stand on its own two feet and keep the
same kind of relations at least that
it's already maintained with the west
for three decades now so there's really
no interest in destabilizing the
situation in kazakhstan but if it was
destabilized i cannot imagine there's a
lot that any western country could do
um unless the kazakh government really
invited them in with russian and
chinese uh acquiescence to that
victor olivich uh over in belgrade let's
cross over to you
we're talking there about china how do
you think china is going to be viewing
these protests i mean the two countries
share a land border and and china has
been increasing its investment into
kazakhstan how do you think it's going
to be
viewing what's happening there now
well of course china is also not
interested in the current turmoil in
kazakhstan as you correctly pointed out
china has been expanding its economic
influence in central asia including in
kazakhstan
and uh of course frequently with
economic influence comes creeps in
political uh influence and
the
kazakh society has been
quite sensitive about increasing chinese
activity and chinese influence in their
country
so on the one hand china is not
interested in the current turmoil on the
other hand uh beijing understands that
the
introduction of collective security
treaty organization forces basically
russian belarusian uh forces some
armenians some others from central asia
into kazakhstan
will increase russia's influence in
kazakhstan and
possibly potentially
sideline
chinese influence perhaps a little bit
in that country uh however since uh
china is interested in stability in
kazakhstan and the region as a whole of
course it has acquiesced to that it's
also important to note that for russia
this
uh peacekeeping mission carries quite a
few risks
if uh russia it is important for russian
troops
not to
engage directly with uh kazakh
protesters or and not to get involved in
any uh in any
real military action because any such
incidents could be interpreted uh and
viewed uh
by
uh various opposition forces in
kazakhstan and outside the country in an
anti-russian manner so in fact it's
important for moscow to tread carefully
here to show support including with
with its uh forced projection in
kazakhstan show support to the
uh current president of kazakhstan to
tokyo and his government uh show support
for stability but at the same time
not to be seen by the kazakh population
as uh as a uh
force from the outside that came in to
pacify
uh or to
uh wage violence against the kazakh
people so that's very important yeah i
want to actually i want to actually pick
up what you're saying there you're
saying there that it's very important
how it's perceived by the kazakh
population on that note i want to ask
asia to silva how do you feel
uh asia about russian belarusian troops
coming into kazakhstan they say on a
peacekeeping mission
i i think it's wrong and uh
and i do believe that we and uh
and our government we need to put all
our efforts to stop violence
that is taking place in almighty and
other cities in kazakhstan but
definitely not by letting a russian or
any other foreign army
carry out a so-called anti-terrorist
operation against casual people all
right i'm we have to leave it there for
time we've come to the end of the
program thank you very much for joining
us here on inside story bruce pania
victor olivich and asiya tulasova
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website al jazeera.com and
for further discussion you can go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
aj inside story you can also join the
conversation on twitter our handle is at
aj inside story from me kim vidal and
the whole team here in doha bye for now
[Music]
you